templates
hi everyone okay
uh i know we're waiting for a gather
time too so not to scare you if there's
a note pass nothing bad is happening
we'll just keep you all abreast of when
it's time to do that
so just a couple of items for you all at
the top
obviously the president just spoke to
the colonial pipeline
and progress that's been made and he was
sending the clear message
there's an end in sight for the supply
disruptions that have affected straight
states across the southeast as you all
know colonial reported
that product delivery had commenced in a
majority of the markets they serve
they expect the plan to have full
operational restoration in every market
by noon today
obviously there's still going to be some
time till things go back to normal
but in the last 48 hours alone we
announced a targeted jones act waiver to
ease shipping of
fuel on top of waivers for epa for a
dozen states expanding gasoline supply
steps taken by dot to make it easier to
ship fuel over land
and a number of other actions across the
federal government
president biden and his team also we
also wanted to thank the governors and
state and local leaders throughout the
affected region
who have moved very quickly in a
coordinated way over the last
several days just wanted to speak to the
unemployment
insurance numbers that came out this
morning
those claims fell to yet another
pre-pandemic
low and while we'll continue to note
that these weekly numbers can be
volatile
the larger trends in initial
unemployment number claims
shows clear economic progress for
america since president biden took
office
since his inauguration the four-week
average of initial unemployment claims
has fallen by over one-third and the
chart
i always love a good chart behind me
shows that there's been a clear and
sustained decrease
over that time frame over the last three
months employment growth
has averaged 500 000 jobs per month
eight times the number of new jobs
created
per month on average in the three months
before he took office
one other note as we continue to keep
you updated on the implementation of the
american
rescue plan today the department of
veterans affairs is highlighting the
launch of the veteran rapid retraining
assistance program
the american rescue plan will provide
386 million dollars
to cover up to 12 months of tuition and
fees and month housing
loans benefits for qualified veterans
who need critical or training to enter
high demand
occupations in addition the american
rescue plan will provide
the department of veterans affairs with
262 million dollars
to reduce the backlog of compensation
and pension claims
by increasing process power and
expanding scanning of federal
records finally uh the senate judiciary
committee today is voting
or has voted i guess uh lots going on
this morning on the nomination of
kristin clark
the eminently qualified career civil
rights attorney to be assistant attorney
general for civil rights
she's one of the nation's most
distinguished civil rights attorneys
she began her career in office in the
office to which the president has now
nominated her to lead
coming full circle along the way she
personally prosecuted crimes based on
hatred and bigotry
human trafficking domestic violence and
sexual assault
she has served at two of the nation's
oldest civil rights organizations
working on virtually every area of civil
rights
voting rights equal education and
employment fair housing and lending
environmental justice disability rights
lgbtq rights
and i could go on if confirmed she would
be the first woman confirmed to lead the
doj's
civil rights division with that jonathan
go ahead
uh a quick one just to start the
president in recent days has been saying
with increasing servitude about his
meeting with president putin of russia
are you able to confirm that even if you
don't have a date or location yet but is
that part of his first trip to europe
uh i don't have any additional details
to confirm at this point in time
uh as we have confirmed from here uh the
follow-up to the president's meeting or
the president's invitation to president
putin
was to have conversations at a staff
level through his national security team
those conversations are ongoing the
president
has said that he has just reiterated
that he hoped that the
violence in israel would soon stop but
it has not done so fast seems to be
escalating getting worse
uh does he see the us having a role
in brokering some sort of calm there
well
uh the role we are playing uh at this
point in time jonathan as we've tried to
keep you abreast of is to
communicate not only with the israelis
and the palestinians
uh the goal and the objective of uh
reducing violence and achieving
a stability but also with key partners
in the region
uh the uh the cutteries uh the egyptians
the tunisians others who can play an
important role and have conversations
with hamas
from that end so i would say that our
objective at this point in time
is to we we have over the last several
days had
dozens of calls at very high levels with
israeli and palestinian leaders as you
know from the president's call with
prime minister netanyahu
the secretary of state also spoke with
uh president abbas just yesterday
and our role is to going to continue to
work not just with the israelis and the
palestinians
have those those discussions move toward
de-escalation
but also with other key partners in the
regions
as we all work toward that piece and one
more on a very different topic
uh the governor of ohio has announced
that they will be doing weekly drawings
of one million dollars
for residents who've received at least
one dose of the covid19 vaccine
uh what does the white house think of
that idea
well in this phase of the vaccinations
uh at the state and local level
leaders are going to take new uh
creative approaches to getting more
shots and arms uh treasury has the
department of treasury has comprehensive
guidelines
uh but um does not typically opine on
each individual program or creative
approach
uh by different states and typically we
leave that up to states and local
leaders to determine as long as it falls
within those specific guidelines for the
programs
should we all be potentially moving to
ohio too
i leave that up to you i i have a
special love for ohio in my house so my
husband's from cincinnati so i have
recommendations if you ever
move there go ahead at least the
president warned
prime minister netanyahu yesterday about
the rising death toll of civilians there
uh well i know we put out uh expansive
readout of
the call that the president had with the
prime minister
uh and in that call of course he
reiterated the right
of israel of self-set to defend
themselves
uh you know in our view uh rocket
attacks from
attacks from hamas into civilian
neighborhoods is not self-defense
so he certainly radiated that but also
reiterated the need
to move to de-escalate the situation on
the ground
his view and the view of our entire
administration is that
the loss of any life a civilian life any
life is a tragedy
and that's one of the reasons that we
are so engaged behind the scenes in this
effort
you sent an envoy to the region is it
possible that you would use this
violence as a vehicle to
launch a new peace process well steve i
will say that
we have been having strategic
negotiation discussions uh dialogue i
should say
uh with the israelis since the very
beginning since almost the
first of the administration now focus of
those discussions or
a lot of the questioning has been
understandably
how we've used that or how we've raised
the iran negotiations and that's
obviously keeping them abreast of that
has been a part of those discussions
but we've also talked about uh the fact
that the position of the administration
continues to be that the only
uh path towards a long-lasting peaceful
outcome is a two-state solution
actually the the fact that colonial
pipeline paid a ransom
making concern that this could happen
over and over again these types of hacks
well first steve let me say that i refer
you to the company for any confirmation
of
uh or comment on uh that particular
question
it continues to be the position of the
federal government the fbi
uh that it is not in the interests of uh
of the private sector for companies to
pay ransom because it incentivizes
these actions leading to your leading to
your point
um i will say that one of the lessons
that other companies should take away
from this
hack is that it's important to harden
your cyber security to take the
necessary steps
to ensure that that you're protected
there are steps we can take from the
federal government
obviously the president signed an
executive order last night we believe
that it's important to increase
cooperation sharing of best practices
between the public and private sector in
a way that hasn't been done in past
administrations
but ultimately it's up to these
companies to take the steps to protect
themselves
go ahead on the middle east uh some
progressive lawmakers have criticized
the president's response to the violence
uh
congresswoman alexander ocasio-cortez
says the president's comments reinforces
the false idea
the palestinians instigated this cycle
of violence uh representative ilhan omar
said the u.s isn't doing enough to
condemn the killing of palestinian
children
what's your response uh well first let
me take the second part of that let me
be very clear
it is a tragedy for the loss of any life
a civilian
a child and we've certainly seen that as
this violence has escalated
our objective and our approach is to
work with leaders in the region whether
they're the israelis or the palestinians
or leaders from other countries who can
play an integral role
in influencing hamas to de-escalate
and move toward a more stable peace
that's the role and that's the focus of
the united states government but
that should not diminish the fact that
any loss of life is a tragedy and that's
what we would convey
and on a very different topic uh
yesterday we saw the president meeting
in the oval office with the big four
or vaccinated in the big blower the big
four
yeah we they were also wearing masks you
know the cdc guidance says that
vaccinated americans can gather in small
groups inside
without masks so why are we seeing the
president model more of that behavior
well they were wearing masks i can
confirm that you all saw that in photos
uh
i know this has ruffled the feathers of
the rnc and i'm hunting
always feel bad about ruffling their
feathers uh but i will say that
uh the focus of the meeting was on
seeing if there's a
way to work for to move together to work
uh toward
uh shared uh objectives of
investing in infrastructure creating
jobs for the american people
and i think that's what most people's
focus is on but the argument has been
that if you can't take your mask off
that may incentivize others to get
vaccinated right to be able to
participate in some of the benefits
of being vaccinated but yet we aren't
really seeing the president
sort of take bleed by example on that he
doesn't wear his mask when he's
outside that guidance is clear um there
were a number of people in the oval
office yesterday
obviously there were there was a whole
press pool but again i think
the big takeaway from the meeting
yesterday i think what most people look
at it and take away
is that the president's out there with
democrats and republicans
they all came out of the meeting saying
it was constructive
looking to see what the path forward
could be about how we can create jobs
and
rebuild roads rails and bridges and that
was what the objective of the meeting
was
glenn just to confirm ohio
is the expectation in terms of the
regional players uh
in the middle east yeah that you guys
want to kind of follow a model
of 2014 perhaps from egypt played a
pretty crucial role
maybe brokering a piece there is that
what you're going for here and your
contacts with those countries
and key players in that region well i
think what our
our objective is in the short term phil
is that uh
egypt tunisia other important countries
in the region
certainly can play a role in conveying
to hamas and leaders of hamas
uh the reasons for uh de-escalate for
de-escalation
and how that could be beneficial and
that's a role they have played
historically at moments in time
obviously every conflict
is different unfortunately but certainly
many of these countries and their
leaders have played this role in the
past and
we certainly look we'll look to them and
continue to look to them to play a role
moving forward
just two quick ones on the economy
senator mitch mcconnell said that
based on the meeting yesterday the
president understands that the 2017 tax
law is no longer a part of the
conversation
about financing any infrastructure
bipartisan infrastructure deal
is that an accurate assessment of the
state of play well what the president
understands is there's agreement
as is evidenced by uh by senator
mcconnell's comments that we need to
invest in infrastructure we need to
create jobs
that bridges are not democratic or
republican they don't have party
affiliation it turns out
how to pay for it has long been uh the
area where they're where we need to find
more common ground
the president's proposed a way to pay
for it we have not seen
proposals that wouldn't raise taxes on
people making less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year so
if they feel that the 2017 changing the
2017
uh tax tax laws bringing it back rate
that were rates with george w bush
president
raising taxes just one percent of
americans is not the way to do it
then we welcome what their alternatives
are just a kind of a broader economic
question
ui numbers kind of underscoring it's
kind of been a bumpy last couple of
weeks
which i think everybody kind of expects
coming out of a once in a century
pandemic
you characterize how important is the
economic
recovery continuing at a decent pace
to your broader legislative goals like
does that does that underpin
your ability to do the scale of the
things that president biden's put on the
table
well i would unpack that a little
differently we know
that continuing to increase the pace of
vaccinations getting more people
vaccinated
is going to have a direct impact on
people going back to work for a range of
reasons
including people feeling safe to do so
including child care facilities opening
up so that people can send their kids
there
and we know that that has had a big
impact of course over time these are
twin crises that
are related but the proposals the
president has made for the american jobs
plan for the um
for the american families plan there are
certainly some impacts that will be
very beneficial over the short term
additional assistance for child
care of course beginning to put more and
more people back to work we know there's
more we need to do more than eight
million people are still out of work
but this is all these are also proposals
and ideas that have a long-term
impact that will increase our
competitiveness over the long term
that will help ensure we can compete
with china so uh
you know there's an argument to be made
that we need to get through
the continue to get through the crisis
we are in but we also need to think
about
what's next and how we're building the
workforce of the future and that will
continue to be his argument just
put a quick final point on it the
broader point being
because of the long-term effect of the
proposals that were put on the table
what happens with economic numbers in
the near term has no
effect whatsoever on the president's
decision to pursue those going forward
well first i would say we look at
averages right
over the course of time so we've created
about 500 000 jobs
on average over the last few months and
we know these numbers and these data
can go up and down uh we also know and
this is why i referenced the pandemic
because
we know that uh there has been a massive
increase over even just the last
month and the number of people who have
been vaccinated uh
as as a in comparison with what the
numbers were in the week that they were
measured for this month's jobs numbers
that was a bit of a roundabout but i was
trying to get to a point there
um so we know that uh there's no
question also an economic
economist have said that these proposals
the american jobs plan would help put
more people back to work there's more we
need to do
but it's both right so it it doesn't
impact the fact that we still need to do
more over the long term for
competitiveness
but certainly as as we still see more
than 8 million people out of work
it is a reminder of the need to do more
now and that the economy needs more now
and that we need to do more now
across communities to create jobs go
ahead
oh thanks i just have a few questions on
colonial and the sure jones waiver if
you're willing
um can you identify the name of the
tanker yet
i cannot i would point you the
department of homeland security okay and
then can you
share anything on the duration of how
long the waiver will be in effect
i think with the president what we've
conveyed is as as
as long as it is needed to address the
supply so i don't i don't
have an additional number of days or
weeks for you and then on
um retaliation and the president
addresses a little bit
but would it be proportional since now
the government believes that these
hackers do live
in
of stopping the completion of the north
stream to
retaliation for this well we continue to
think that nordstrom 2
is a bad project as you know uh but we
there's still an ongoing investigation
obviously this president was speaking to
what we know now uh but in terms of the
conclusion of that uh we would point you
to the fbi and in terms of what steps
could be
taken that would likely be recommended
by cyber command and we're just not
quite there yet
on the table is there any discussion
about north carolina we're just not
quite
quite there yet
back to infrastructure given this red
line that republicans
have when it comes to corporate tax
increases
would the white house be willing to
accept
not paying for part or all of this plan
if that's the only way to get a
bipartisan deal
i don't think we're quite there yet you
know the president proposed a plan to
pay for it
because he thinks that's what we should
do
we're going to have a discussion he'll
have a discussion with senator capito
five ranking members of important
committees play a role here
about uh how to move things forward
we'll see what they come forward with
obviously we say take leader mcconnell
at his word but
there are a lot of players a lot of
members on both sides who have a range
of views about this in terms of what
options should be to pay for it
whether it should be paid for the
president's red line or i hate that term
so
his line in the sand um is in action uh
he's open to a range of proposals but
you know we're not going to make that
decision unilateral early but democrats
have been open
to not paying for infrastructure in the
past yep they have been
but there are a number of players that
will be important as we move forward
these propos
these proposals these negotiations uh
and we're still at an early stage of
those
this process you've said many times that
the president wants to see
progress on this issue by memorial day
is that code for if these bipartisan
negotiations don't bear fruit within the
next few weeks
democrats are going to go it alone i
wouldn't say it's that uh
clear of a line in the sand just to
continue our analogies here
uh but we will have an assessment after
a couple of weeks about how things look
and whether it looks like there's a path
for it it doesn't mean it's a moment of
halting or not halting
as you know there will be discussions up
until the moment a bill passes
with democrats and republicans
regardless but
it will be a moment to assess where
things stand and what the right steps
are moving forward given that's a time
as you all know
many will go home for congressional
recess and then finally on israel
why hasn't the administration
prioritized naming
an ambassador to israel and will uh
that name be in the next batch of
ambassadors that are
made by this white house well i would
expect we'd have more in the coming
weeks on
uh an ambassador nominating an
ambassador to israel
but i will say and having lived and
served at the state department for a
couple of years
we have a very talented trusted uh
career uh diplomat
who is there on the ground who is fully
engaged with the white house
um is fully engaged uh with uh with
leaders in the region
uh and as is his entire diplomatic team
so i think it's important for people to
understand it's not as if
work halts uh just because you haven't
had a nominated and confirmed ambassador
that's important
but the system of governing career staff
foreign service officers are in place so
that there can be the continuity
uh through administrations uh go ahead
um thanks jen on colonial i know the
president said that he didn't want to
comment on whether he was briefed uh on
the payment but
just to put it a little bit more broadly
was the administration aware at all
uh whether a payment or not was made i'm
just not going to have any more on that
um and then my colleagues are reporting
that uh legislation to overhaul the
military justice system
is gaining traction in congress this is
the bill
led by senators gillibrand and ernst um
this is broader than what the pentagon
is looking at doing
through the commission is this something
that the president would support and has
he had any conversations with
members of the senate yet well uh let me
first say that
like the president recently said we have
to have an all hands on deck
effort to end the scourge of sexual
assault in the military
uh underlining that sexual assault is
repugnant at any time and then we have
to uproot this horrible long-standing
problem
as he promised during the campaign he
ordered the creation of an independent
review
commission on sexual assault in the
military to take bold action to address
sexual assault and harassment in the
force
under what it's a 90-day process i think
they're around
halfway through that 90-day period of
time so
obviously these reports about support in
the senate are positive
um it's a welcome development uh we will
see how that process moves forward
nothing's passed either body of congress
at this point in time
and even as it's working through the
work of this commission will continue
and sorry just to follow up on nancy's
question um real quick
is the president committed to paying for
the package fully or is that
tpd right now the president's proposed
uh
uh
uh ways of paying for the his proposals
uh because he thinks that's a
responsible thing to do
uh but again there's going to be a range
of discussions with members of both
parties as nancy said
some democrats think we don't deport
republicans feel
very friendly about that some in the
middle feel strongly too or feel
which way that's part of discussion um
so we're still
having those discussions we're in the
sausage making um
and he's proposed uh ways to pay for it
because he felt that was a responsible
thing to do when he put out his ideas to
the public go ahead david
a few questions on colonial jim um the
president of one thing
in the statement today said that uh
he was going to take steps to disrupt
this network
and then he was asked later on does that
mean return cyber attacks would he rule
that out
he seemed to say no
he wouldn't roll it out he would not
roll it out that was
that was clear so um is his idea here
something similar to what cyber command
did last year with another
ransomware group where they actually
stopped them from
getting on their servers in an effort to
try to keep them from disrupting the
2020 election is that the model that
the president has in mind i think we're
not quite there yet david obviously this
uh just happened just a couple of days
ago
um you know he was providing an update
to the public and being transparent with
all of you about what we know
as it relates to the investigation that
investigation is still ongoing
at the fbi and obviously cyber command
would make recommendations about next
steps
as we often like to say some seen some
unseen
but i can't get ahead of where we are in
any internal process
so when the president said that this
happened from russian territory
was he suggesting that
if it happens from your territory as we
often say in
in terrorism is used this came up often
when you were at the state department
that the country from which an attack is
launched
is as responsible for it as the
attackers themselves
i would say he's uh making that clear
because certainly the host the country
where individuals are located
even as a criminal network even as he's
confirmed
uh that we don't have information from
our uh review
process that suggests the government was
involved there's still
some responsibility my final question to
you
goes to your reluctance to discuss
the ransomware issue i'm trying to
figure out
if on the one hand the government has a
policy that
of recommendation why isn't it in your
interest
to call out companies that might
actually
violate what both the fbi and the
treasury department have
recommended strongly in fact
redepartment went beyond that last year
they
they said that there could be sanctions
uh against people who
uh uh pay uh ransomware
so i'm trying to understand what the
theory is
in not calling them out if you know the
answer to the question
well david i would say that it's the
recommendation of the fbi
uh to not pay ransom in these cases as
as you well
know uh for good reason because it can
incentivize
uh similar attacks additional attacks
deceives
uh other question but again our policy
remains
that's our recommendation but that
private sector entities or companies are
going to make their own decisions so
what i'm here to do is just convey the
policies of the united states government
and it doesn't feel particularly
constructive to
call out companies in that manner at
this point in time
go ahead thanks jen what does the
president think about republican
governors such as
mike parson and missouri reducing
unemployment benefits
in order to force workers back to work
well what we've seen um we know there's
been a lot of
talking points and chatter out there uh
suggesting that
uh reducing or benefits
300 a week in most cases benefits to
people across the country would
incentivize them to go back to work and
frankly we find that to be
a bit off off track because what we've
seen in the data
is that the actual issues at play here
are the pandemic and people needing to
address things like child care
being fearful about going back to work
before they were not vaccinated
so states governors are going to make
their own decisions but
it's important to convey i think that
when you look at the data when you look
at the fact
that's not we have not seen that as a
widespread driving factor
in people not going back to work
how will the president deal with the
nearly 100 billion
in back rents that would need to be paid
in order to avoid evictions
once the moratorium expires i know that
moratorium is something that has
which is hence i'm sure why you're
asking about it has helped many many
people across the country
get through this very difficult period
of time i think we have a little bit
more time before it expires if i'm
remembering correctly
and certainly there will be
considerations made but it's it's a
process that's done through different
agencies and secretaries and making a
recommendation on the extension
uh so i can't get ahead of that um if we
don't make the decision to
to extend it obviously we'll have to
figure out how to continue to help
renters but
at this point in time it's still ongoing
breaking news do you know if the cdc is
changing its guidance
today about mask wearing indoors
i don't have anything i can uh preview
for you on cdc guidance that would be up
to them
uh go in the back thank you um
the the head of major teachers union uh
is saying
that all schools should return to full
capacity in the fall what what's the
position on that
we agree yeah okay just change um on the
putin summit which may or may not
happen a number of americans
are being held in russia we've talked
about them before trump
uh reid and for instance has russia
after any concession
in return for their release
in return for their release from us in
return for their release
obviously the uh detainment of
individuals by the russian government is
something that we raise
uh at the highest level uh and certainly
it's raised through many diplomatic
nulls
in terms of what those negotiations and
discussions uh look like i'm just not
going to be able to give you more
information on it
real quick the markets have been very
volatile this week
uh it's giving a lot of heartburn to
people who are saving for retirement and
other investors how concerned is the
president about that volatility
and about inflation well on the markets
i've been doing this long enough not to
weigh in and speak to that
um certainly we have a number of people
in the federal government including our
treasury secretary who can speak to that
more effectively than i can
i will say on inflation uh what we are
we take
that very seriously uh our uh the
expectation from economists
uh both inside and outside of the
government is that uh the impacts of our
proposed investments are
transitory are temporary and that the
benefits far
outweigh the risks so that we look at it
through
certainly through that prism obviously
we've seen
over the last couple of days to your
point some reaction to the cpi numbers
that came out just yesterday and you
know
our view on that is it reflects the
reality of an economy that's rapidly
turning back on because of a successful
economic strategy
and if you dig into the data there are a
couple of factors at play that i think
people are
taking a look at now that we've dug into
the data more including the fact that
you know for example airfare has
increased by 10 but are still almost 20
below pre-pandemic levels uh the
one of the biggest impacts we saw in the
data yesterday was on
used car sales and that is a direct
impact of the semiconductor chip
shortage so
point is there's a number of factors
here that can be
explained and we're working to address
and i think as we
continue to communicate that um
hopefully that will give some
comfort to the american people and of
course industries
go ahead a couple questions um can you
confirm that the white house is seeking
changes to legislation that would grant
statehood to the district of columbia
and change it so grant the electoral
votes the winner the popular vote to
deal with potential constitutional
concerns
um well um we have issued a statement of
administrative
poll administration policies you know uh
strongly backing
the bill and our view is that admitting
dc as a state as well within congress is
power
and that the arguments to the contrary
are faulty uh but we also think there
are ways to allay the concerns that have
been raised and that's why we're working
with congress to
make the bill as strong as possible as
would be the case
in any nearly any negotiation or about
any piece of legislation
can you confirm that those are the
changes that you are seeking i'm not
going to get into more details of it
other than
we uh certainly uh would support um
d.c statehood and strongly back the bill
on infrastructure can you um
you've talked a lot about progress by
memorial day can you define what
progress specifically is
is it um is it uh a deal in principle
with senate republicans
is it passing surface transportation
bills out of committees
or is it what is it what is progress to
you
well i think as i was saying in response
to nancy's similar question earlier
uh it's just a marking point for us to
make an assessment of
what we think the path forward looks
like and as you well know from covering
congress
everybody will go home on memorial day
recess it will be quieter over near the
capitol
obviously there'll be a lot of activity
as you all have seen this week
and that will continue both at a staff
level member level
engagements with the president other
high level
members of the administration and we'll
have a feeling on what the path looks
forward
looks like moving forward uh i i don't
want to define that at this point uh
because that's not really to our
advantage there's a couple of weeks
before
memorial day and we'll just be able to
take stock of where we should proceed as
i've said before obviously the president
wants to work in a bipartisan manner
he thinks there's opportunity to do that
he was encouraged by the openness to
that in the meeting yesterday
and obviously he's going to sit down or
is sitting down shortly you'll
know uh with uh with leaders uh here
uh but um uh but his only his only line
in the sand is in action
discuss the foreign nuclear talks with
the prime minister
we regularly brief our israeli uh
counterparts um
on uh our ongoing negotiations and
discussions with iran
rob malley is uh currently taking part
of those now
as an important partner in the region we
do regularly brief them
uh i don't have any update or anything
in addition to add to the readout but it
was primarily focused as i think
uh as i think was clear on uh the
the escalation of violence uh happening
on the ground at this point in time go
ahead
yes senator tom cotton says the nation's
wealthiest colleges are
indoctrinating young people with what he
calls un-american ideas
he is proposing a new tax targeting the
largest
private endowments uh he says it would
raise two billion dollars a year
i wonder does the president believe that
our largest
uh our wealthiest schools are
indoctrinating our youth with unamerican
ideas
and would he support such a tax is it a
good idea not even intrigued me
what are the un-american ideas that are
indoctrinating our youth
the legislation doesn't lay off the
precise oh he's not specific about the
indoctrination by leaders from
universities
well he's been critical of for example
the 1619 project he's been critical
and spoken about critical race theory
he's uh
he's claimed that there's a liberal bias
on campus that
targets conservatives i think would be a
way to put it what's he going to do with
the money
uh he wants to use it for programs for
my hard time coming up with the word
when you have job training
uh those sorts of things
well uh without much detail of where he
thinks
our youth are being indoctrinated it
sounds very mysterious and dangerous
although i don't think that i don't
think we would think we believe that
uh educating uh the youth and next then
leaders of
the future leaders of the country on
systemic racism is
indoctrination that's actually
responsible but i would say if he's
trying to raise money for something
um then our view is there's lots of ways
to do that
we know that a number of corporations uh
hugely benefited financially during the
pandemic
they could pay more taxes we think the
highest uh one percent of americans can
pay more taxes and if he wants to have a
conversation about worker training
we'd love to have him over and have that
conversation
follow up we have a bridge over the
mississippi river
at memphis linking arkansas and
tennessee it's had to be shut down
because there's a crack
in it um is this fluke or should
americans be concerned about the
structural integrity of their bridges
and
what if anything is the administration
doing to
address this problem well first i would
say that's an excellent example of why
we need the american jobs plan
and as you know probably traveled across
that bridge a few times yourself i would
guess
there are bridges around the country
that are decades
overdue and being repaired and being
fixed and ensuring that
people traveling they're going to work
they're taking their kids to school
are up to the standard that we should
have in this country
in one of the most competitive and
industrious countries in the world
so that's a good example of uh why the
president's proposed
um repairing bridges around the country
repairing roads and railways
and the good news is that will create
millions of jobs so there's a win-win
for communities around the country
uh go ahead in the back sure just report
that
and former emmanuel be appointed to the
u.s ambassador to japan
soon i don't think you can combine it
but i know the
to deal with china and north korea uh
well
i do expect i know there's a lot of
interest in this uh i do expect we'll
have more in the coming weeks
on nominating ambassadors to uh servant
obviously once confirmed
important posts around the world and
japan is certainly one of those
important partner in the region
important partner in addressing
stability and security in the region and
certainly
we would see that person as someone who
would play
an integral role however i would say
there are a range of
a range of positions from the state
department from our national security
team
that may play an additional role or
significant roles as it relates to
negotiations moving forward so
i don't have anything to preview on that
front
going back we've heard repeatedly with
respect to the statements about violence
in israel that
israel has a legitimate right to
self-defense but we're not hearing about
the palestinians right to self-defense
why is that
and does the president believe that
palestinians have a right to
self-defense
well let me first say i think it's
important to note as i think you'd agree
that these rockets are coming and these
attacks are coming from
hamas and many palestinian people are
put
being put in danger because of the
violence that is happening back and
forth and
the president in his uh great statement
yesterday
uh also um made clear that
we um you know uh he underscored the
importance of working to advance peace
throughout the region including between
israelis and palestinians any loss of
life any threat to life
which we've certainly seen is a tragedy
that's we're working to de-escalate and
try to reduce
uh in the region in the statement
that palestinians also have a right to
self-defense
are the attacks not coming from hamas do
you consider hamas
the palestinian leadership let me
rephrase the question then
you've repeatedly in the statements
condemned the rocket attacks
does the white house does the biden
administration also condemn the
evictions
of palestinians from their homes in
october we have spoken to that in our
readouts and
certainly our national security advisor
has raised and we have raised at many
levels the
importance of uh of uh addressing
uh the building uh in these in these
communities and the fact that
uh you know in order to move forward and
move toward de-escalation
uh that's an important issue to address
so that has been
that has come up i think we've got to
move on and let you wrap go ahead
why when secretary blanken called both
muhammad abbas
and also benjamin netanyahu why didn't
the president do the same by only
speaking to the israeli prime minister
are you concerned that this shows sort
of a one-sided viewpoint from this
administration well i would say that the
secretary of state is an incredibly
high-ranking
member of the administration fourth in
line for the presidency if i'm getting
that correct
he's very close to president uh biden uh
and
uh certainly that sends a clear message
about the importance of
communicating uh with all parties in the
region and we have also had
dozens of calls with a range of leaders
in the region as i've conveyed
to the egyptians have you sent any sort
of message to
us through the egyptians well i think
steve the reason we're
of course talking in part to the
egyptians and others uh
in the region is that um they have
significant influence over hamas
and uh unfortunately as we saw earlier
this week assurance from hamas
uh that they were prepared to stand down
prove false as they later launched a
rocket barrage but
they are important um uh you know
communicators uh with hamas uh
they can play an important role uh here
and that's why we're communicating with
them as well as the israelis and the
palestinians
thank you thank you everyone
you